and hello good afternoon thank you for
joining me I'm really excited to be here
and share with you a little bit of the
work that I've been doing in this space
in making so of that I'll just get
started so as Michael said I consider
myself an accessibility researcher and I
approach everything from a human
centered computing lens which really
means I really focus first on who the
user is and then I start thinking about
what are the opportunities to match
technology to that um one thing that I
like to kind of do when I'm starting out
explaining my approach to research and
one thing when I'm considering about
accessibility research is that
accessibility and thinking about what
are the opportunities for technology is
a lot more complex than just matching
somebody's ability or a diagnosis to
some kind of technology that could
magically overcome or fix this and I
draw a lot from disability theater or
sorry disappear disability theory that
looks at kind of the medical and social
models of disability if you have
questions I can talk about that later so
in addition to understanding an
individual's ability I spend a lot of my
time working to understand specific
populations or individuals habits and
preferences and use all of that
information when I'm thinking about what
are opportunities or challenges for
technology and this really impacts the
methodology that I use in my research
the first one is user collaborations so
many of you have probably been hearing
about participatory design as a method
that you can use where you invite your
user group into your design team I like
this image that shows one of my PhD
students Michelle Williams designing a
wearable piece of technology with a
woman who's blind you can tell it's just
a clipboard on some string but it's
really powerful in terms of talking
about what the opportunities and
challenges might be about neck worn
displays or technologies the other thing
that I really incorporate into
everything that I do and I was talking a
little bit about this at lunch with the
PhD students
is really thinking about longitudinal
fieldwork the different I'm gonna today
highlight a bunch of different groups
that I've worked with and every one of
them has a story that's usually a pretty
long one where I go there make
connections get to know the organization
and then involve them in research which
is a little bit different from some
other kinds of HTA research where you're
able to go off and send out a
recruitment email and then just have a
whole bunch of people show up so it's a
it's a bit more work and this is
something that I've been doing for a
long time this actually is an image of
United Cerebral Palsy Center in
Pittsburgh where I spent many days a
week as a PhD student both volunteering
and doing long-term observations and so
I do all of this work in my research lab
which is called the pad which is a
prototyping and design lab where we have
a bunch of different kinds of digital
fabrication tools we build stuff in
there it's a space to be noisy space to
be messy but if you go there on any
given day you're probably not gonna find
a lot of students there because most of
the time we're out in the field that's
where we go to our participants rather
than bringing them into our messy
chaotic space so today I'm going to talk
about a couple of different things I
want to start by talking about the
vision and the opportunity that I see
for the DIY and the larger maker
movement to revolutionize accessibility
and specifically assistive technologies
I'll talk about my initial vision and
work that I had done to kind of evaluate
the feasibility of that vision and tell
you about some of the things that aren't
so great about that vision and then I'll
switch gears and in the making making
accessible component tell you a little
bit about some of the tools and training
efforts that we're doing to really help
Rawdon the group of people who are
involved in making and then my favorite
part is always that so what did you
learn I have a lot of recommendations
and suggestions from all this work that
I've been doing for the past several
years alright so the first one is
talking about opportunity so if any of
you have taken or about to take any kind
of
assistive technology class you will
learn pretty quickly that assistive
technologies are really really broad and
many of us in this room are actually
using assistive technologies right now
right so many of us are wearing lenses
they're able to correct our vision that
are able to help us see more sometimes
there's a very traditional assistive
technologies things that you can buy in
medical catalogues things that come from
a prescription and covered by insurance
but then we're also seeing people use
other kinds of technologies such as
these kinds of games or there were like
we bowling leagues for a while is ways
to get people to exercise that are more
kind of reappropriation objects that are
in the world and using them as assistive
technologies so I just wanted to call
out that I think of a very broad
approach to assistive technology where
it's anything that you're using to then
let you do something you couldn't do
otherwise so it sounds great right like
I've called out a bunch of assistive
technologies some of us are using them
other ones you've probably heard about
seeing you know people who are using
them like we're done here right
assistive technologies help people do
things at the end right like that
shortest talk ever
no but there's this huge problem so even
though like lots of people have worked
to solve the engineering problem
figuring out how to make a technology
that meets the ability need it turns out
that a lot of people don't actually use
the assistive technologies that they
have for them and there's a whole world
of people who study the abandonment
rates of assistive technologies I like
this one study that has a number that's
about 30% of assistive technologies that
people get end up on the shelf but if
you look in the breakdowns of which
different populations there are for or
what activity is there for you can see
abandonment numbers range from like 8%
all the way up to 75% and the highest
numbers are usually with things that are
around hearing aids because people don't
like the perception of looking disabled
so there's a whole bunch of theory there
if you're interested but what I found
really interesting is looking at well
what are
that these abandonment researchers say
or why people are not using the
technology and it's that they're not
it's that their habits and their
preferences really are the things that
are being overlooked people are more
focusing only on ability so I think this
is where DIY comes into play we're doing
it yourself offers the opportunity for
people that have more customization get
things faster have things be more
affordable and this could impact the
abandonment rates so I want to talk
through just like a couple of those
concepts and hopefully try and convince
you why there's so much opportunity for
DIY to really help with this the first
one that might be the most obvious is
the speed right so if you're doing it
yourself you're doing the design work
you're doing the fabrication then you're
in control of the amount of time it's
going to take for you to get it if
you're someone who's getting a power
wheelchair that can take like a year
from when you initially are recommended
to have a new power wheelchair form when
it's in your house that's a long time
also if you're doing it yourself you can
be testing it at home or in your
favorite coffee shop or whatever your
context of daily life is rather than at
this specific clinic where everybody's
watching you and they're really like yes
this better work you better like it
because it took us forever to get it
here and it was really expensive the
other thing is that doing yourself can
be very appealing because you might not
have to interact as much with insurance
a lot of assistive technologies the way
people get them is actually through a
prescription that then gets approved by
insurance and then goes out to bid and
then goes out to and it's just this
whole timeline there's a lot of people
involved there's a lot of things that
can go wrong so it's very appealing to
have it be faster also doing yourself is
appealing because it can be very
customizable if you really want to have
the thing be pink you can make it pink
right you can really design things to
fit in with your daily life within the
other objects or technologies in your
life this is an image that I really like
to also illustrate this of an
exoskeleton for a young girl that's made
out of like 3d printed parts and rubber
bands
and so if you're thinking about
designing technology for people whose
abilities are constantly changing fast
turnaround and customization for what do
they need today can be really really
important
and finally do-it-yourself can be super
affordable yes there are these catalogs
I have this example of a cup holder that
attaches to a wheelchair for a hundred
and ten dollars you could go to your
favorite hardware store and buy the same
materials for a couple of dollars and
when we're talking about you know
resource constrained populations price
is really attractive finally
do-it-yourself
is really empowering this maker movement
has been very popular in the past few
years I would say that even is coming
out or alongside you know the popularity
of HGTV people cooking more Martha
Stewart right like people are really
proud of things that they make some of
us wear scarves that maybe aren't very
like well crafted but we made it
ourselves or someone we love made it and
so we're willing to wear it we're
excited to use it this can also be very
empowering for people who might be used
to receiving things going shopping or
Corps doing things through catalogues
and really not having much control and
this idea of that can be really
empowering and in terms of us and
motivating it when I was this came from
some initial read interviews that I was
doing and I found this quote that
someone said when I when it breaks I
stay in bed to be very powerful and the
idea of being able to control if you're
able to go outside by changing some
things having some control of your
assistive technologies is really
important so I just want to call out
this idea of doing yourself is not new
at all anthropologists have documented
early humans using like animal horns up
to their ear to amplify sound or there's
a long history of people having some
kind of foot or leg injury making
crutches out of materials that are
around or Therese will comb has known as
kind of the MacGyver of assistive
technology knows every kind of tape and
every kind of clay to make any kind of
grip that you ever want but there is
something fundamental that's changed
within the last 10 or so years that I
want to talk about and that is these
maker tools and maker communities that
have been developed so oftentimes like
if I were to give this talk 15 years ago
and I were to talk about making tools
you might think about tools like this
but these tools are not very accessible
they make a lot of assumptions about
ability they're making assumptions that
you're able to remember different kinds
of steps to do to use this safely you
have some kind of specifics about vision
that you're able to see details you're
able to see or hear lights or sounds
come on and motor abilities and as a
result a lot of people are not able to
use these kinds of traditional making
tools and you can contrast that to this
new generation of tools that I generally
call digital fabrication tools that then
if you can access a computer you can do
most of the work in terms of fabricating
the physical object I think this is
really really exciting within this
ecosystem of different tools
I feel the 3d printers are the easiest
for people to use and probably make the
fewest assumptions about the end-user
because theoretically for the most part
if you're able to you know slice your
model and hit print at whatever stage
and then it goes you can then get it off
the plate we're laser cutters you need
to worry about fire CNC Mills there's a
lot of thing so I kind of I focus on 3d
printers because I think they're the
easiest for people to get started with
and 3d printers are now everywhere I
love that cusco was selling dremel 3d
printers with you know manufacture
rebates Amazon has a whole bunch of 3d
printers that we could probably get here
in an hour for under a few hundred
dollars if you can't or don't want to
have one of these in your home there are
lots of places that you can go and have
objects made for you tech shop or other
kinds of like you know maker gyms where
you have a subscription and then you
have access to tools but they don't need
to be in your home or what I think is
really exciting is business models like
shapeways where you can send creative
files send it off and then have it
mailed to you and if you think again
about physical accessibility or
assumptions about users that's all
computer access
right if I can use my computer and do
the design and send my file it'll come
to me in the mail and that can be really
exciting and really accessible so along
with all of these physical tools are
these tools that can make these physical
objects there's been also a huge change
in terms of people sharing things that
they were made and this coincides with
lots of things that people are doing
online where they're sharing things that
they did ideas that they had people are
collaboratively working together to
solve problems online and many people in
this room are studying these online
communities or thinking about other ways
to support these activities but I think
it's really important here where you
might not know anybody in your area with
your same ability but you could imagine
networking with them and finding them
online and sharing resources so you both
can share some kind of new tool yeah
Michael our what percentage of them can
actually use these things that your what
an amazing question so I did this kind
of analysis of the stage and was
starting to figure out like how much
people would want to participate and
that led me to the study that we did in
2014-2015 to figure out who was actually
doing this and why so I'm gonna tell you
about a study that we did it was a
systematic review of things that were on
Thingiverse so show of hands who here
has ever heard of thingiverse.com
ok so about half so fantastic so this is
an online community that also acts as a
repository who hears use github or knows
what that is yeah ok
so it's github for designs for physical
objects where people are open sourcing
their designs you can't just say here's
a picture of the thing that I made like
you could on Instructables but you have
to say here's the thing that I made
here's the file you can download it
yourself they have lots of different
ways for people to fork designs and then
post and share and ask questions it's
very collaborative people often I like
this example of people making pillow
holders and then even showing their
failures like it's too small but I
didn't work and it's a community to help
people do that so for this research this
community had been around for a while
and was really the place that people
were getting started and people were
talking about things that they were
making and it was really really popular
and it had been several years since I'd
been doing some of the thought work of
what are the opportunities studying
abandoned rates and so I had that
question of well what's happening like
the maker movement was at peak or close
to it and I wanted to know like well how
much of the stuff on Thingiverse is
actually assistive technology what kinds
of assistive technology are people
making it or what kind of are they
making and why are they doing it so what
we did was we did a systematic review of
designs that were on thingiverse.com
we came up with like a huge number of
terms so we had I guess 171 terms that
then gave us like 25,000 things to sift
through and figure out all right in our
most generous definition of assistive
technology how many of those would we
consider an assistive technology okay
does anyone want to guess what
percentage of things on Thingiverse
might have been assistive technologies
seventy okay okay I like those numbers
that was what I was thinking too it
turns out less than one percent were
things when we gave like our most
liberal definition of assistive
technology could we classify as
assistive tech so at that time
Thingiverse had about a hundred thousand
designs and we were able to find like
three hundred and sixty-three and we
spent a lot of time broadening
broadening
and broadening our search so here on the
Left I have images of different
categories of things that we found and
then on the right the ranked list of the
popularity actually it's not the
popularity but it's just to match that
diagram so the most popular kind of
assistive technology on Thingiverse was
medication management tools pill boxes
which are readily available at your
24-hour drugstore so in terms of like
how much of the need is there you know
these are not expensive things and you
can buy them all over the place yet this
was what we were seeing the most of
people making I expected there would be
a lot of things like the wheelchair
mounted cup press things from catalogs
and it's like all great now I don't have
to spend a hundred dollars hey I figured
out how to do this
here you go six percent of the things
that we found fit into that category
there were really really not many and
then I have some examples there of other
things that people had if you're
interested in this we wrote up a really
nice summary of what we found this is an
analysis that we did okay of those
things like who's interacting with it
like I mentioned a Thingiverse has
support for people to collaborate for
people to say hey thanks so much for
that design I made it and post pictures
of the thing they made for people to
remix it in the middle row that shows
the things that people were making the
most popular thing that anybody was
making that was assistive technology was
a spinner ring that had Braille on it
and again if you think about like what
are some of the challenges that people
are facing and some of the problems with
assistive technology use I'm not
convinced that Braille on a spinner ring
is really like that high of like a
priority for anybody there were also a
lot of things that people were doing
around 3d printed hands as you can see
so those were things that people were
making a lot of it was things that were
being posted that people were liking but
not a thing that people were remix thing
the bottom row is the okay I downloaded
your version of it
and now I've put it put a new version so
the things on the left were things that
had Braille on them somebody made a
really great Braille library so it was
really easy to put Braille on objects if
you were energetic so we see the spinner
ring and then this little tactile globe
and then of course we see some of the
pillboxes see so that was useful but we
still didn't really understand where
this stuff was coming from and why so we
did an online survey of the 363 things
there were 273 designers and so we
emailed and contacted all of them and we
heard back from 69 of them to get them
to participate in this online survey to
understand why they had made this thing
and put it up on Thingiverse and to
learn a little bit about them and there
were a lot of people who very
altruistically and kindly were making
this for somebody that they know and in
the paper we break out exactly what that
relationship was if there's some of
their family or a friend of a friend
only like less than half of that were
people then who made it for themselves
which was really the target demographic
that we were expecting and I think it's
interesting to note that the same number
of people who are making assistive
technologies for themselves was the same
number people who are like well I
thought it would be a good way for me to
practice my 3d modeling skills people
who saw this as a personal challenge and
then the numbers the motivations go down
from there I don't have the numbers on
the slide but of these people very few
of them had any kind of assistive
technology training or any kind of
medical experience for the most part
they were people who were engineers who
were already familiar with making
digital fabrication 3d modeling and they
wanted to try this out or apply their
skills so what does this all mean like
where is the state like how can I answer
Michaels great question well the thing
that is happening is we're seeing people
start to make assistive technologies may
be moving a little bit away from ok you
can only get these things from these
catalogs and through insurance so people
are getting them faster
we're seeing things that are definitely
affordable right and we're seeing we're
starting to see some things that are
customizable the library for Braille is
a great example of the technology
supporting customization but I have this
questions the lingering question of well
is this empowering is this kind of
fitting in with the larger goals of the
maker movement and all of that marketing
that gets us excited about making things
for ourselves like how is it different
if someone is giving you this device and
they made it versus if you buy it
through the more traditional channels
and while I don't want to discourage
people making things for other people I
think it's important to think about what
is the sustainability of those things
after they made our people making things
that maybe are not actually good for
that person to use a lot of people have
been very critical of the 3d printed
hand movement both in terms of the
number of people who have exactly that
kind of limb loss is very very small but
then a lot of the 3d printed things that
people are making are really heavy and
so actually for that limb it can be
really bad to use and would not be
recommended but because you know there
was a Boy Scout Troop or somebody you
know who made it for you that individual
might feel obligated to use it and be
putting themselves at risk and I think
it's really important to think about
these issues as we're continuing to
think about well what is the future of
DIY and accessible making and how do we
not have it be a thing that then it's
like if you make your own object you're
going to be dropped from your insurance
which could be a real problem
and so what I want to transition to for
the rest of the talk is the work where
I'm thinking more broadly about well
alright how can we make making
accessible to both end users and the
experts and clinicians and maybe we can
move a little bit to having them be able
to do it and have build up a culture of
kind of responsible making and then
we'll see this explosion that we were
hoping for
so within this space I've been focusing
I started thinking it was all about
tools and then I actually ended up
switching gears and realizing it was
more about training so I'm gonna go over
just really briefly a couple of the
tools that we had design and I think
they're most useful to think about not
in terms of wow these are
technologically impressive digital
fabrication design tools but they're
really I think carefully designed tools
that fit in with this ecosystem and
conveyed these ideas so I'm going to
talk about two of those and then I'll
talk about our work teaching this kind
of stuff to physical therapists and then
also integrating it with in special it
alright so the first one that we did was
a project called vis touch like several
of you and we're thinking about what
cool stuff can we do for good and
accessibility when we're talking about
digital fabrication tactile graphics
came up and so for those who don't know
there's a long history of people making
tactile graphics at home and for a lot
of both parents and teachers hand make
these because you can get them
professionally made but they're really
expensive they take forever and it's
often a lot faster so we're working
within a community and culture that
already had a lot of DIY Ness around
creating assistive technologies so I
love this example where you can make it
out of glue and glitter one innovation
is to use puff paint to make tactile
graphics particularly numbers or you can
make tactile graphics using different
kinds of embossing technology that
ranges from really really inexpensive
pin pen to really expensive machines
within this base we specifically focus
on tactile graphics for math we were
working with some teachers and learned
that in classrooms where students had a
range of visual abilities the blind kids
got fewer examples than the sighted kids
and we heard a lot of stories and
instructors who would like stay up all
night trying to make examples for their
students with visual impairments but
they just would get tired or there would
be something and they needed an example
on the fly and they weren't able to
really keep up so there was a real need
for this so we did something that was
really relatively simple
where we created this really simple form
based interface something that I think
looks nothing like a 3d modeler or a
creative tool where you could just enter
in information to automatically create
this tactile graphic that you could
upload like a spreadsheet or you could
upload enter in an equation and get a
simple graph of it so from this which
would take you know a few seconds to
fill out it would automatically generate
a 3d model so the 3d model could be
generated in a minute that would then be
ready for 3d printing we then the 3d
printing of these things took about an
hour which yes is a long time but again
if you're thinking about an instructor
preparing materials for the next day
this is way better than staying up all
night
huffing like the glue this is much
better they can still do that on their
leisure they prefer yeah and so this is
one example here showing like an
equation and then also kind of playing
with what can you do with data we were
starting to think about okay what are
the things that you can do with
different heights to that you can do 3d
printing that's a lot harder to do in
the manual things we also learned that
there was interest in playing with
Braille so for those of you who know but
a bit about Braille there's actually an
ISO for Braille in terms of the spacing
and the size of letters now you can have
it be whatever you want because some
people have different kinds of
sensitivity and actually cannot feel
Braille also Braille literacy super low
for people with vision impairments or
who are blind so people who are low
vision actually wanted alpha numerics on
there instead of Braille or they even
wanted to feel the letters a number so
it was a really flexible interface that
we thought solved this very specific
problem another example was again
working with a school but this was a
very different where we're working with
physical therapists who were helping a
student who wanted to use a stylus to
access her iPad so this school like many
schools received a whole bunch of iPads
and they were trying to figure out what
to do with them
and there was this access problem for
this one student the physical therapist
had tried every grippy clay spongy grip
thing on the market and none of them
worked for the students really unique
hand contracture so we ended up doing
was we went there and we gave the
therapist some clay they put the clay to
get kind of an impression of that
students shape we then 3d scan the clay
and then from that we were able to 3d
print it poke a hole in and put the
stylus in so we did this and you know my
grad student like marched back and
really proud of herself holding the
stylus with the grip on it she gave it
to the therapist and they said well
that's never gonna work
she has a different stylus it's bigger
and I'm like oh ray
oh man we'd put in all this effort and
then we realized oh whoa wait a minute
all we need to do is put a bigger hole
in the grip and so we did that they're
new and fit and now she's able to access
her iPad her array but we realized there
was this larger opportunity for again
one of these like really really simple
tools that we call grip fab again like
simple form based design where
therapists can enter measurements I've
been really and surprised and impressed
some clinicians are very nervous about
numbers and math but they are amazing at
taking measurements and they can tell
you to the millimeter or to the fraction
of a degree exactly what something needs
to be and so interfaces like this
they're totally fine using so we created
many different versions that got more
and more complicated I think this was
the final grip with the stylus and then
we wanted to have it at an angle so she
could use it for eating and hold a fork
and whatever else and so we were really
really encouraged by this kind of stuff
so from that we said okay well maybe the
clinicians as designers how can we
really empower them to adopt making how
can we really bake this into their
practice excuse me led us to this work
of working with clinicians so the way we
approach this was we were working with
the University of Maryland Baltimore
Medical School and they have an intro
class to 3d printing
and they came to me and they said you
know we really what we've heard a lot
about making and there's all this
pressure to integrate fancy technology
into our classroom can you help us so
what we did was we created a three or
depending on the semester three or four
semester three or four class series
where students would learn about 3d
printing first class was de mystifying
3d printing for those of you who are
more kind of like engineers you're like
whatever but if you're someone who's
coming at this from a medical background
you might have a lot of ideas about what
3d printers can and cannot do and you've
never seen one so de mystifying that we
did exercises where they would create
assistive technologies out of clay for
imaginary patients as their homework and
then we took their clay away from them
because that model works really well we
went off in 3d scanned it and then we
brought back the finished designs and we
even let them iterate so then they could
hold the physical object and say okay no
actually there needs to be a hole here
this needs to be bigger this needs to be
smoother or whatever kinds of
modifications and then we did that work
and so we've done this we're doing this
for a third time this semester just to
give you a sense of kind of what we did
again since these students were starting
out and this fit in well with the things
that are naturally doing in the class
the instructor created these different
case studies where there were imaginary
patients where they had very clinical
descriptions and then for us like HCI
people we needed layman terms to
understand what the case was and
students would start by drawing I was
really encouraged to see these drawings
that were significantly better than
anything I can draw that were very
sophisticated and looked a lot like
engineering drawings this one is showing
how a grip could fit on a cane to
support limited wrist mobility so we
have a picture of the drawings and then
on the other side the thing that's made
out of clay that's a red and green and
then we 3d scan that and then a 3d
printed version here's just a different
version where they had a different case
that was thinking about crunch grips and
how you could support it the green one
was made out of clay you can see the
drawing the
made out of clay and then the black one
was 3d printed and for the most part
this is working and we're continuing it
and we're actually now trying this with
real patients so they have an actual
clinic and so having them the students
come in and try and do this and that's
going on right now so we don't have
findings but a lot of I'll get the
lessons learned from this and we learned
a lot from that all right the other
activity that I wanted to hit on was
things that were doing in special
education we actually started this work
by working with a high school that
specifically serves students with
cognitive impairments we were working in
their technology classroom we gave them
a 3d printer we gave them lots of
training we gave him a grad student we
did everything we could and we just
weren't able to figure out ways to fit
it into their curriculum so we learned
pretty quickly this was not gonna go
very quickly so what we ended up doing
was we designed our own 3d printing
class that we taught on our campus and
it included students with intellectual
disabilities UMBC has a four-year
post-secondary experience program for
students with intellectual disabilities
where they take classes on campus and so
for the juniors we created a 3d printing
class for them we taught this class
three times the amazing thing about
teaching a class is then you have
control every session is data how people
are learning and what's happening and in
this they learn 3d printing I learned
how to operate a 3d printer and they
learned a lot of 3d modeling tools the
thing that was unique about this class
and the way the program was structured
was every class was what they called
integrated which meant it was half
traditional degree-seeking students and
then half students from this program and
so what we did was we had these students
learning this new kind of technology
learning these new skills doing this
design work together and this actually
became one of my PhD students
dissertation topics is how do these
really really diverse groups learn
together I think there's a lot of
opportunity because neither
one of them had ever done 3d printing
before so nobody was the expert
everybody was on the same playing field
despite this huge difference in ability
and overall it was really really
successful like I said we've taught at
three different times the other thing
and how we got people to take this class
was it was a 3d printing for
Entrepreneurship class it was part of an
entrepreneurship program so again it's
like here's this new technology here are
all of these opportunities to change
business and change things so we had
students designing things they could
sell we had them there's this pile of
rings that they 3d printed for like a
client and also did some of their own
custom design work and I think this
aspect of incorporating entrepreneurship
into accessibility is really important
and really responsible when we were
working with the population that has
like a 60% unemployment rate and so the
students in this class learned these
really advanced skills they learned how
to design even if they never did
anything with 3d printing again a lot of
these skills transfer to other kinds of
work and we've seen students from this
program go into like data entry
positions and other things which is
fantastic ok so those are all the things
that we did what did we learn right the
biggest thing and I have some citations
and I probably could have put like every
paper I've ever written time is the most
expensive resource and if you were to
ask me why are people not doing this I
would say it's either they don't have
the time to do it or they perceive that
the amount of time it would take they
don't have and this just came up time
and time again no pun intended
so the example we were doing the grips I
told that story in a way that made it
sound like really efficient that
actually took months and the reason was
even though the therapists were like yes
we want this student to be able to
access an iPad that was not their top
priority they were working through how
do we help make sure that her hands
aren't stiff how do we address her
communication aids they had all these
other priorities accessing the iPad was
kind of in the 9
to have so we had lots of ther and also
her therapy happened during school so it
was a 45 minute session where she had to
be pulled out of a classroom moved into
another room and she would actually get
settled and then we were like okay now
we can do the thing it was like no no we
can't do the thing today so just waiting
for that took a really really long time
and so the advice is to really
understand the cycles of when this kind
of work can happen I think this also
fits in like with the design tools like
we design things that really could be
the therapist or the instructor could be
in and out in a minute right they
weren't intimidating they looked really
quick they understood it it was art in
the language that they were speaking and
thinking and that really reduced a lot
of the barriers yeah Michael
absolutely people put in time align my
mental model with with this and I'm
ganna understand is it something where
the benefit is just not perceived to be
sufficiently worth the time so like you
know the front door in my house is gonna
die soon like the lock is gonna just
stay locked and we're gonna have a
problem yeah but like it's never like
quite worth it yeah fix it yeah and you
know in despite this being something
they have to deal with all the time yeah
just in that world where like I I can
muddle along and I'm doing other things
time time is not itself the problem it
seems like it's some other pressure
other priorities there's a lot so it's
complicated to that and to really
convince you that time is the priority
or time is a huge thing and what's
slightly different about the
accessibility and I would say even
educational world is that we're talking
about people who in their jobs don't
have time right so especially if you're
an education instructor especially and
you have your students and they have
their IEP s these are things that are
priorities that are maybe even tied to
insurance or resources that the schools
getting and these are the things that
need to
and we see this in other educational
environments too where it's like math is
the priority and that's why we're having
less time for art and music right and
it's just like those are the priorities
and they're set by somebody else and we
need to do those things and so that's
very very real also there's the
acceptance that kind of in the
accessibility disability world things
just take longer and so as a result
fewer things happen and so then again in
addition to okay I have to learn all of
these new skills that's just like you
know moving from this room to another
room is really really important it has
to happen but that's gonna take probably
longer for some people than others and
there's all kinds of unknowns so like
they're really you're working with a
population that's already over
constrained and taking time to do things
there's only so much time but that's
assuming you're trying to fit it into an
educational environment I think there's
a real opportunity to fit it into other
things that people are doing how can you
build it into recreation time or other
sorts of things that people are doing
that might be more flexible rather than
straight therapy time where you're
billed by the minute the other thing of
course is there's already like a lot of
educators a lot of therapists are
overburdened in terms of additional
things that they need to do because they
care and they're passionate and so then
if it's like okay I need to learn some
kind of like whole new technology thing
that I've never done before and maybe
I'm not super confident with technology
that's just really really a lot to ask
the other thing that I want to kind of
comment on about time and this fits into
a totally different research project
that I'm working on is I think we also
need to acknowledge that luxury time or
time for like academic learning in that
true sense or tinkering time is a kind
of privilege and so really thinking
about who has that luxury to spend time
to investigate search out different
kinds of printers fiddle with the
printer all of that stuff so it's really
complicated and we've seen it come
across like I said in many different
contexts and I think it's really really
important to think that through in order
to either get access or in order to have
results to show it's complicated
the other one is designing with familiar
tools we did not think that clay was
gonna be the thing but oh my god is
totally the thing um the things that
people can do with clay that they cannot
do in 3d modeling is impressive clay has
a bunch of limitations though that you
do need to consider but for this
application clay is actually great
because the same constraints of if you
make something out of clay are kind of
similar to the constraints of what is 3d
printable and so if you can make it out
of clay and it can stand up there's a
good chance we'll be able to 3d print it
so without actually teaching them any of
the physics of 3d printing you can just
relate it in this way that makes a lot
of sense to people another piece of this
that I wasn't expecting that really came
out with the physical therapist is
around identity and as non-engineers and
so if you take people who really
identify as non engineers and have maybe
made a lot of choices to go to grad
school in medicine rather than
engineering if you then ask them to do
tasks they perceive as engineering
they'll often be self-defeating and so
how can you kind of trick them into do
this or make it ways that are relatable
to them where they're not going to be as
intimidated and a lot of us we also see
in making with younger people or how do
we have inclusive like CS curriculums
for girls it's a lot of the same stuff
but it was something we weren't quite
expecting with the physical therapists
the other is to anticipate a steep
learning curve I love this example as a
3d printed thing that I think this came
from the class with the two students and
this was their you know this time it was
make a house and this is what they did
and for those of you who have any
experience in 3d printing you see all of
the reasons that this will you can't
just hit print and this won't work also
there's like some really complicated
things about like well what is 3d so
this actually came from the physical
therapy class where you know the warm-up
assignment was make a snowman they were
totally into it you know these were
younger people in medical school these
are the ones who worked some intimidated
by 3d modeling tools and it looked great
and then you rotated it
you realized that they were designing in
2d and not 3d and so then you kind of
have to ask yourself this question of
okay how am I going to teach them what
3d is how much time do I have to do that
are they going to be resistant to that
how is that all going to work much with
will it print there's the whole question
of will it scan so people will make
amazing things out of clay that are not
easy to scan so we've done some work
where we're kind of showing what you can
do with off-the-shelf inexpensive 3d
scanners but we're also really lucky
where we have access to direct
dimensions which is a professional 3d
scanning company and so when we have
really exotic things were able to
sometimes have them bail us out and scan
that thing but there are a lot of
difficult technical challenges that you
have to teach someone in order to design
something that is 3d scannable the other
one is choosing the right equipment so I
love this story about why you can't just
drop a 3d printer in a space and say I'm
done I change the world and now
everyone's going to be a maker so this
is a 3d printer that was at a school for
the blind and they got this donation
this is a really expensive at the time
probably like a twenty thousand dollar
printer and they had the printer and
they had all the materials printer was
stored in a closet because it's an
expensive thing we don't want it to like
walk out the door and then on this
printer bed I should there's a photo of
literally everything that had ever been
printed on that 3d printer okay and so
this thing was not getting a lot of use
there are a lot of reasons for that
number one this was a I'll say just a
powder printer which means that if you
drop it it will shatter and turn into a
pile of powder and if you ever hang out
with blind youth you will quickly learn
that things end up on the floor all the
time right and so this is really bad
which is again why all the 3d printed
objects were carefully tucked away in
this closet that like only a specific
person could access the other problem
with this and part of the reason this
printer is so expensive it was a
full-color powder printer which wow what
an amazing generous gift but for the
students who can't perceive color come
completely useless right so again
there's a whole world of different kinds
of these tools and thinking really hard
about how do you match that up to your
target population the other one is size
matters an interesting thing we learned
about the physical therapist was
everything needed to be one-to-one scale
they made some really big things the
first time we taught this class and we
were running short on time because our
schedule was too aggressive and we
didn't have the 3d print time so we said
you know what we'll just make smaller
versions and they'll be able to like
imagine it was the same size so these
are little shoes that could go on the
end of like a crutch or a cane and I
swear we brought it into the class and
the students laughed at us they're like
nobody could ever use that those are
like doll shoes right no they hadn't
designed the thing they had designed the
giant doll shoe and they thought that
would be an assistive technology but
when we made it little they were like no
that will never they couldn't imagine
that translation and so we quickly
learned to sub sizes for them on terms
of how big of a thing we would make for
them and make sure everything was always
one to one the other thing that we saw
was that materials really mattered
physical therapists that we're working
with did not like anything with jagged
edges or wasn't smooth they loved
everything that was a flexible filament
for those of you have worked with
flexible filament it is difficult to
print with it takes you have to print
slower there's more failure it's really
annoying but we've just seen that's what
they want and everything needs to be in
that material and so some of these
tricks that we know about in terms of
giving prototypes just did not work in
this environment we really had to have
the one-to-one in the final version in
order for them to imagine how they would
use it and accept it and then the other
one is encouraging collaboration we were
amazingly surprised and encouraged at
how successful the class was with these
two really really diverse groups working
together and working in teams we're
doing this team-based learning a little
bit in the 3d printing or the physical
therapy class - which i think is part of
why it's successful as people are
learning this new skill together but I
think there's a difference between two
people learning together and more
there's a whole world of educational
literature that could confirm that
but that's kind of what we're seeing
here this really works and especially
when nobody is the expert they're
learning together people are more
willing to accept each other's ideas
alright so what's next so there's a
whole bunch of things to do I'm
continuously kind of studying what's
happening in the DIY movement what's
happening in terms of assistive
technology yes that survey we did a
Thingiverse was a few years ago we
haven't rerun it yet but I'm pretty sure
these fundamental challenges haven't
changed yet so but maybe I would love to
be wrong um where what I'm doing now is
studying the impact of teaching these
skills to non-engineers so continuing
with the physical therapist ramping that
up a little bit in terms of like what we
can get them to do both technically and
in terms of thinking and looking at what
are the opportunities for maker
employment I started doing this in the
class with students intellectual
disabilities but I've recently started
doing this with youth so on the new
projects I did was open up a 3d print
shop that employs youth in Baltimore
that is part of an after-school
makerspace so this was a place where
students would go and they would learn
all kinds of cool 3d printing skills
programming skills all the stuff and
they have they offer classes and
activities for students up to the age of
18 but in Maryland once you're 14 then
you can go apply for a work permit and
so actually retaining teenagers in these
kinds of academic after-school problems
was programs was really hard so we've
started creating and exploring well what
are the jobs that people who've been
through this can do and so we have this
print shop and now this print shop is
the one who build and prints all the
things that the therapists are designing
they're doing the 3d scanning they're
doing the 3d printing so we're building
up kind of this ecosystem where we're
able to maybe have a more sustainable
model of people who are doing the making
yet having the experts doing the
designing so that's the new thing that
we're feeling out thank you so much for
listening I think we still have time for
questions
so happy to answer any you have thank
you
somehow we can how you can increase
caleb yeah so that's a great point and
it's a conversation I've been having
with a few students here is kind of
making that decision of where you want
to go once you have some of these ideas
there's a lot to be done there in terms
of adding complexity adding
generalizability you could imagine doing
this for any kind of math and I
encourage everyone to do that and I know
some of the technologies you guys are
developing are probably better at you
know creating all kinds of tactile
graphics than that specific one we
design that to really solve that
specific problem of okay here's a math
class here's an instructor who wants to
do this thing how can we make a tool
that they'd be willing to use what I
wanted to do and just was never able to
because the Clara deserves of working
with or not at that school anymore it
really sucks was to actually make a
whole math book right and so that way we
could then have a whole curriculum and
really test this out and that's really
the thing there that I think that work
was missing before I would want to go
scaling up the technology we had done
several kind of you know 1/2 hour
interactions some tasks can use this
work what do people think about this as
a technology but before I would want to
add to the complexity of development I
would first want to do a feasibility
test of this idea there's a great debate
how does a lot of people of should it be
these you know hard plastic physical
objects or should it be some kind of
dynamic display there are good arguments
for both and before like adding the
technical complexity to this I would
first want to do that evaluation and
partly that's just my approach to
research but you're completely right
that there are a lot more sophisticated
things that we could do but I would want
validation from the teachers that this
is even the right path yeah a great
question yes so when you started
the universe is really excited about the
potential of like well I could get to
that point where they're getting this to
find myself a cast like me you prince it
or like a a or like good ergonomic
immune or whatever and yet I think work
you did kind of didn't really go in that
direction because like right like at the
end of the day like once like the
therapist does their you're a little
thing like like they're like none of
that stuff being shared online like it's
still kind of a walled garden it's still
this bullet model you're just you're
just using fancier technology to create
things do you think like you could
defense your transitions like more like
a more open like perhaps a bounty driven
or something kind of way to direct the
making of this so that the end result is
going to be accessible yes and I
encourage everyone to create assistive
technologies or create things and
publish them and share them openly
contribute to these kinds of communities
the goal of my research and our research
lab is to more understand how this
technology might work rather than push
any specific design for a while I
thought maybe like you know we'd be the
tactile graphics team and we'd really
lean into that and again making text
books and but we realized because this
is so new there are so many other things
that we don't know we're also not and
you know an an orthotics group where
that's really not our strength as HCI
researchers so more we want to
understand and empower other people to
do that there I also skirted this but
something I could give a whole talk
about of like well what are the
liability issues if one of my students
or I or somebody else make something
puts it online somebody else uses it and
something happens and I think a lot of
people are still figuring this out we've
done some interviews with physical
therapists and they have leaned more
towards well if it's somebody who's a
certified physical therapist and they
make it that's cool and it's kind of
then up so long as the is then up to the
end-user to make that decision and the
therapists if it's prescribed but it's
very very complex so that's part of why
to the things that the students are
doing in classes were not
pushing them to be publishing but these
communities exist and if anything there
are we're starting to see more and more
people in facebook and parents groups
sharing that's out so I think that's
happening organically because other
people are like yeah I made this caste
and I want to share it in my research
I'm more interested in kind of like
studying that or understanding what are
the reasons other people aren't doing
that naturally it's a great question
yeah it seems like there's probably a
complex and you know interrelationship
between tools yeah but if you're
somebody who wants to make an impact in
their way those technologies do you have
a sense or feeling as if there's sort of
an equal opportunity or in the space of
developing tools or training and
facilitation community building it's
sort of all of it everybody needs all of
it right like and even if you're
thinking if you outside of the space of
accessibility we still see lots of
people who are not engaging in these
activities even though there's so many
reasons to do this and there's so many
opportunities so I think there's always
the opportunity for more tool develop
and more sophisticated tool development
we totally need that sometimes I relate
this to cooking right where I think of
my kitchen as a makerspace and lots of
people have really sophisticated maker
spaces in their homes yet a lot of
people still get takeout right and so if
you think about well what is the real
reason people aren't engaging in this
there's this also then in that metaphor
goes to there's always new tools that
are coming out in the kitchen market
then get people who never had done it
before to start cooking so I think
there's still a lot of space just and
there's value in all of them and then I
think it just kind of depends as
researchers kind of where what impact do
you want to have what resources do you
want to have we're also seeing lots and
lots of companies who are developing
really cool and exciting tools and so I
think it's really exciting to see more
and more of that happen so there's so
much space for that and then as we have
more of an ecosystem of those tools then
we can even start figuring out like what
are those good for who's appropriating
those tool
what populations are those tools
accessible how can we make them more I'm
starting to see some people looking at
you know and what are the accessible 3d
modeling tools for people vision
impairments a lot of it has been
text-based 3d modeling and so then is
something that a screen reader can
access but there's lots of cool tangible
things I think some projects even in
this room that are happening in that
space there's so so much that can be
done and I think we're just still really
really early on in all of this yes and
back when do they want
I do not know much about them yeah so I
look them up and then think about them
there was also another hand in the back
somewhere about like what I should be
making what would come from the OTT yeah
they yes and also don't really have time
to say well it's like custom build
something that might work for this task
though yeah II don't know that you even
want to do because they don't really ask
they just kind of have a list yeah I was
wondering if you see that model changing
at all or wait how do you see that going
it's a fantastic question um part of the
hope and part of the reason why I'm
working with physical therapy
instructors is to maybe be part of the
next generation of people with that
training who then also know about these
tools and can build it into their
practice or encourage other people to
I'm still not convinced like until like
billing changes that physical therapist
would be the ones to do that but I could
imagine they make the first pass at it
and then they give a tool like grip AB
to the end user or they give them the
Tinkercad file and then that person is
able to do the customization or just
even showing that as possible and as
more people get to talk about it see it
becomes more common than we see that
culture develop so I hope but it
it's gonna take time just like other
innovations I mean I think it is
fascinating within some of these medical
fields some of them leaps and bounds
lots of changes happening other ones not
right and I mean that's part of just the
structure of the medical system and
liability and priorities right people
might be much more focused on movement
than activities of daily living or even
leisure activities even though that
might be the thing that the individual
really wants to have the most I think
it's also interesting that you brought
up the issue of control and you feeling
maybe unsure about having that much
control what I really see happening and
kind of maybe the next kind of
generation of this is that more end
users are the designer where we're
seeing more of a participatory design
approach and then they're partnering
with somebody else so maybe has some of
the technical skills or they're using a
tool that is really accessible to them
and that way they can really be the ones
driving it so it's really complicated
and interesting found that the
therapists are really resistant to
anything that's not tried true and
tested and you'll be run against that
and if you found anyway the only people
that are interested are the 18 people
and they're just doing their little
thing for Ken yeah their pisser yeah
like no thank you give me 20 years yeah
so that's real and then I think it gets
into some of the really interesting
liability issues so the most extreme
version of that that I've seen was
working and talking with people with
power wheelchairs and again it's like
when it breaks I stay in bed and that
was somebody whose power wheelchairs
broken and then they're just waiting for
somebody to fix it in some of my
interviews and work I've talked to
people who are willing so the end user
is willing to go against what the
therapists say and even violate their
insurance or their warranty if they're
involved in it which i think is
tremendously exciting right so like
power wheelchairs are crazy expensive
like fifty thousand dollar pieces of
equipment you're really dependent on
this but there's again the consequences
of not having it is so severe that
people are like yeah well if I can be
involved and I can be making the
decisions and I'm in control then like
let's do it let's solve it
that can also be a personality and a
resource decision so I don't think
there's a clear answer it kind of also
depends about how we see more people
making taking control rather than just
relying on consumerism I think is
probably what's gonna dictate that
attitude that you're seeing perhaps if
we then have more medical professionals
who are familiar with these tools
understand what some of the dangers and
risks are and have a better sense of
what they are rather than thinking
they're magical complex engineering
machines then there might be more
freedom but it can also be really tied
to personality and identity so I hope so
yeah
[Applause]
you